we learned the administration announced
that they are unfreezing six billion
dollars in Iranian oil revenues as part
of a prisoner exchange and what
essentially amounts to a ransom payment
that Joe is paying the mullers in Iran
which comes amid a new report today that
Iran may be able to produce as many as
10 nuclear bombs in four months here
with reaction Texas Senator Ted Cruz uh
I didn't think America paid Ransom
payments uh to mullers in Iran uh so
they can spend more money on their
nuclear program Senator I must be very
naive
well you you you should be outraged
because what they're doing is they're
placing a bounty on every American's
head what this Administration is doing
is sending six billion dollars to the
Ayatollah the Ayatollah who routinely
chants death to America and death to
Israel and you can rest assured that six
billion dollars will be spent to fund
terrorists who use it to murder
Americans and to murder Israelis not
only that now that the Ayatollah and
every other terrorist on Earth knows
that the Biden Administration is willing
to pay billions of dollars for American
hostages you're going to see more
Americans take it hostage because
they've suddenly made it a profitable
Endeavor sadly this Biden White House
puts partisan politics above our
national security interest and and I
gotta say their Iran policy is
spectacularly dangerous for Israel and
spectacularly dangerous for the United
States let's get your reaction to the
impeachment inquiry if we can get you to
put your legal hat back on Senator I'm
sure you probably would rather be called
an attorney anyway but
seriously the walls to me seem to be
closing in he lights Joe lies
spectacularly Joe is involved up to his
eyeballs the family was enriched Hunter
had no experience Hunter was an addict
at the time uh tens of millions of
dollars involved grandchildren paid
shell Corporation set up what do you see
well I think today was a very
significant day today the House of
Representatives announced their formerly
opening an impeachment inquiry into Joe
Biden I think that's exactly the right
thing for them to do I've been calling
on the house to do this for many months
now and and you know one of the
interesting ways to to assess what's
going on is to look at at the Biden
White House's shifting stories and you
played quite a bit of this in your
monologue started off with Joe Biden
saying I've never talked with my son
about any of his overseas business
dealings turns out that was a lie their
next story was I've never done business
with my son and his overseas business
dealings turns out that was a lie you
know the latest talking points Democrats
are are trying to trot out in response
to this impeachment inquiry is there is
no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement in the corruption
so they've pretty much given up on
Hunter yeah Hunters corrupt is the day
is long but there's no direct evidence
of Joe's involvement that's what they're
saying now that's a flat out lie too but
let me break it down in two pieces
number one and in a trial in a legal
proceeding there are two types of
evidence there's direct evidence and
circumstantial evidence now what is
circumstantial evidence I'll give you an
example if you go to sleep tonight and
you look outside the window and you go
to sleep and the street is clean
and you wake up in the morning and you
look out the window and there is snow
covering the ground that is
circumstantial evidence that during the
night it snowed but you know what it's
pretty damn good evidence circumstantial
evidence people are convicted and sent
to jail every day of the week based on
circumstantial evidence circumstantial
evidence is you draw inferences from the
circumstances that's compared to direct
evidence direct evidence is testimony
from someone who said I saw it snowing
last night that's direct evidence
there's at least two instances of direct
evidence of Joe's corruption number one
you played on this show which is Joe
Biden's admission in front of the
Council on Foreign Relations that he
held a billion dollars of U.S taxpayer
get loan guarantees hostage in order to
force the firing of the Ukrainian
prosecutor who was investigating the
Ukrainian oligarch that is one of the
critical elements of bribery of the quid
pro quo quid pro quo as you know is
Latin for this for that the that Joe
Biden has admitted to that is direct
evidence that he's admitted to the only
question is is there the quid is there
the five to ten million dollars of
payments now on that there is
circumstantial evidence there are the 20
million dollars plus of payments to the
Biden family and there is also the
consistent pattern of obstruction and
covering it up which in any court of law
you would draw a negative inference from
I can just give you a little preview of
Coming Attractions I believe that
money's been found senator stay tuned to
this show and we'll let you know more uh
thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else